hello peeps I'm solo rapport since 2:00
today Bryan Callen decide to miss
whatever a few housekeeping notes for
you this week Dallas Thursday Friday
Saturday all shows almost sold out early
show Friday has the most tickets
available if you're looking to get
frosty Dallas this week
Dallas Addyson improv Salt Lake City is
next week wise guys those shows are
muscled out Thursday Friday Saturday
Salt Lake City Utah coming and then just
announced ice house Pasadena the night
before Thanksgiving that is November
27th with Bryan the kid count me and
some friends my grand old time man it's
gonna be so fun and then Kansas City
December 6 through the 7th Atlantic City
New Jersey New Jersey get your tickets
one show one night only
December 14th just posted just one on
sale today la jolla a Comedy Store
December 19th through the 21st get your
tickets now tip at kake.com I'm getting
so just call it's called guest hosting
if this guy shows up he shows up he's
not gonna show up he just text tell them
to suck my [ __ ] let's start the show
let's start the podcast I'm guest so we
can have that ginger oh thank you and do
the waves and how long the airport what
time flight 255 there's nothing worse
than the guy who's so stressed about
their plan no no we're [ __ ] you know but
it's it's not about two hours early it's
about getting there on time just like I
show up here on time just like I'm now
guest hosting the fighter and the kid
today because your co-host be shooting I
mean he's on that show but he's not on
all the time so it's like I told mother
[ __ ] last night I said don't be late
would you see Methodist or the Laugh
Factory he didn't have a spot he just
shows up there he didn't go on who does
that the last thing I want to do
anything more lonely at what was at 11
o'clock 11 o'clock at night oh I'm not
sure you there if I'm not working what
the [ __ ] would I be why are you there
it's 11 o'clock at night there's other
comedians percent of lives that's why
right do you have lives and so so let's
can I send some guest hosting can I take
the lead let's do it bro welcome to the
fighter in the kid my name is Michael
rap
today I will be filling in as guest host
with Brendan Schaub I believe that the
last time I guess hosted it was the
highest downloaded fighter in the kid at
the time there might be bigger sign
there's bigger ones now Lee Chan
laughing no it was true yes dryest okay
so there's some big boys but I think
that if we broke that record now what
would that do to irritate Bryan Callen
your your your co-host who didn't show
up to that here's thing he doesn't know
how to look at the views on YouTube so
who ape yep well Bryan would have no
clue I called him II he doesn't look at
social media or nothing so he looks at
social media if he does you know what if
it's to go back and forth with Chris
D'Elia and like oh like oh we're like
playing like you know I hear a man or
look at chicks I grew muscular chicks or
muscular dudes he's on there you know
what more than but I know right now he's
like media he gets sensitive you call
them out on it too that's how you know
you know like if you say some if
actually hurts you get really defensive
that's right he's that right so I think
the fans too cuz I'll say this I get
recognized for a bunch of different
things knock on what I'm blessed super
bug I mean do 7,000 show super blessed
for sure calm down but but yeah one
thing that I always get consistently
always it's not like everyday but it's
consistent you got to go back on the
fighter and kid you gotta [ __ ] with
those guys so here I am
they are the other guys not here w guys
not here I'm gonna stuff them and I'm
gonna stuff you stuff stuff you I'm
gonna dominate your britches bro you're
used to Stephen H Smith and doing the
ESPN shows and see it Bayless and
Shannon Sharpe rap I will [ __ ] your
world up Brandon print it listen to me
you realize you've been on this PR tour
and what do you what am i providing what
I don't wanna take the lead sits up
covers what no what no what are you
sorry no it's not here's a backhand
smash yo its back it's like here's what
48 typical season 3 which you killed on
or even on Netflix great show you should
watch it now that
I know people love that show I do see
that a lot on social you how old's your
son he's three and a half meat for
February new baby comes in two weeks
your new baby yeah son oh [ __ ] I didn't
know how to swim
yeah girl or boy another boy oh [ __ ]
congratulation well your well your son
you should watch it cuz I think number
one as a dad you'll it's you'll really
dig it it's a real touchy though I can't
watch like kids that are sick no no no
no no it's touchy but it's not touchy
because of the the the health thing okay
the one son is autistic okay but that's
not what the show is about like have you
seen euphoria yes it makes you not want
to have girls yeah yes
let's assume that's like all high school
I mean you should know that I mean got
guy like you in high school and college
you probably not like that dobro they
were in the drug [ __ ] and thrown the
[ __ ] the spitting on the [ __ ] oh my
god it was so aggressive
oh my god like a trend among like they
they know it at young music I didn't get
spat on by a woman I have my thirties
maybe I had no this is like pro quo
here's the thing the young kids yeah sex
and drugs it's not a big deal
it's like this are you shaking hand into
these girls yeah what's up bro yeah hey
what's up bro
that would like spitting is the new
hickeys yes spitting on spitting on you
is the new hit yes all reeks man so I
got a tip I got a triple kill every
season three and there's gonna be a four
we're waiting to find out I feel good
about it
I'll assume I feel good about it I'm
proud of the show it's a good show it's
a sweet show the the range of people
that like it is is broad I hear about it
all the time by the way no change for
the support thanks for checking I mean
like I guarantee you when you had like
who were some recent guests on that
you're not that friendly with like you
we're friends we tapped you and I are
boys yeah who suggested like they came
in they were all like ly Rob Schneider
Rob
here I want to talk about Senate live
with them for the entire hour two hours
we didn't have you had questions lined
up for him he didn't we didn't touch on
it him and Brian talked about I don't
doing stand-up not even that I don't
like member back in the days when we
were developed a tip nobody even that I
wish they would have went there but oh
did he put him to sleep they both put me
to sleep who was a guy Oh Rob Schneider
though I love it but who was the guy
that they were like kind of excited they
didn't know them that I could save like
it came on the Shelf come on Gary Owen
maybe okay Gary oh right he came on but
here's the thing he came on cuz Brian
talk [ __ ] about him and Gary DME was
like dude fire people sent me all the
night sky yeah great guy he was like
people to send me all these notices like
what's up with your boy Brian cuz Brian
which he never does especially with
comics or [ __ ] about him not even talk
[ __ ] a great career does arenas and [ __ ]
like that Gary I mean kills in theater
him and Mike Epps are coho had laid
Berger comedian in Bryan Callen correct
correct
mmm I bigger actor bigger comedian well
could you say bigger actor cuz I also
want to say about count
I went signals two shows on ABC he's got
two shows any shows oh he's on the gold
ruled and it's the same show right
regurgitated what do you think about
Brian Collins the big I was like I was
at oh [ __ ] he's gonna be in the joke
right show the Joker twice I've yet to
see Bryan Callen in the java stuff it's
tough it's tough I mean he's in there
you know what that's called being cut
out of the movie he got cut out
that's Colby I mean like him he must
have worked the day anyway so was it a
big part to me give me one you know what
the shitty thing is you toe is a bad
friend I knew he's cut out a movie
six months ago but I didn't tell him
wait how did you know we was in the
movie that's you know let me tell you
something the fat on out my boy he got
cut out of the probably the biggest most
exciting most anticipated and then
fulfilled the anticipation movie of the
year is so Brian camera billion dollars
over billion dollars worldwide
it was scrutinized are people gonna go
see it iconic iconic it'll be around
forever it nobody is in it it
Weiss and and and I've heard he was cut
out but then I'm like I I went to go see
it the first time I didn't I didn't even
know he was did you notice Mark Marin
though
yes he's barely in it to the barely and
he went to the red car hey guys short
there's a red card we know that that's
from dude I'm not showing the red carpet
unless arm I gotta be a mane yeah well
you know you know liking me on there he
can have them on there beyond his
podcast well they're right because you
know do you know have you done man yet
I've done Maron twice oh really dude oh
man I dunno merry I also know him now as
a stand-up because you know I'm in
stand-up I'm performing this weekend in
Portland at the helium comedy cover V
dumb Portland how dare you I'm asking
more times four times the Portland yeah
great club one of the best clubs in the
country I was there when the proud boys
protest was going on there and then I
gotta [ __ ] with you well here's a thing
while I look Mexican but they were like
I don't know if you should come or not
all the show sold out I think the proud
ways helped me yeah
Shawna Jordan one of the I don't know
like the real protest the city was shut
down I was stayin in the middle of
downtown the protest was around my hotel
I went outside just to check it out and
it was pretty dope got a pretty classic
picture of me proud boys bunch of squat
like Danny whiny smoke with you now
they're all cool everyone's cool
um so back to Portland so you in
Portland Portland this weekend here Leon
first time in Portland first time
performing at Portland and my first time
in Portland I'll do part that's great uh
good coffee doughnuts good food I'm
going I'm going to trail boys this game
and I'm wearing a blazer at the
Trailblazers game I mean [ __ ] so I mean
okay and next week um in Sacramento
where it's at punchline great club have
you performed there yes three times okay
and then I'm gonna be Philly Boston the
rest of your Philly helium yup
dude you're doing it right Boston Wilbur
that's all of science big boy talk your
I'm sorry
laugh use me did you do over I sold it
out with a podcast but I haven't you
know stand up new to me so I start to
bubble yeah but you know you know give
me you see you you see me up there go
and stand on ya know here's that here's
the thing about you though I was talking
about this was all with another miss
Delia
meet me Whitney Krista Tom are you doing
it's different than I don't wanna call
people it's different than like an actor
doing stand-up because they have no
other options you've done stand-up
before yeah oh well want you tried it
before I know it started as a stand when
I was 19 there you go and you have gift
of the gab like it's your thing but you
could do crowd work for an hour and kill
the room that's right
no you're super talented and Whitney
Whitney knows that maybe D'Elia was like
questioning he's trying to figure it out
while he was like he hated on you a
little bit hey Dom of course he did no
I'm just you know the comedian it but
you know what's funny about comedians
Khomeini's go dude I've been doing this
20 years and and they're like they're
all scrutinizing and questioning you you
get a job on a movie set actors are like
dude I've been doing this 20 years this
is like oh you're there like it's just a
different reason you're there there's a
reason you get this reading you there
but it's also there's a reason I'm there
that's what I'm saying that's right
here's the other thing you know the
haters with the comedians they're not
indifferent mean less with you cuz
they're physically intimidated that you
might smack their knowledge out of their
mouth mm we've talked about of course in
general of course there's haters but we
that whole thing that company doesn't
but the thing difference between acting
in comedy of course acting can't act you
didn't get [ __ ] acted off the goddamn
set especially with the big boys that
you're the shows you're in yeah but with
stand-up it's very black and white very
black and white gives a flying no [ __ ]
your name first life meaning whatever
pot got you have your stripe minutes our
happiness you don't even get five
minutes maybe when you're on the road
helium import a bond you get five
minutes right call that godlessness do
it all time right they want they want
you in LA if you're a guy who's famous
trying to stamp you get 30 seconds so
are you oh that's the guy from that show
on whatever show what our movie and then
go mother yeah you got a show behind you
is D'Elia
it's [ __ ] you know Big Boy yes yeah
Joey Diaz Rosenberg yes it's not gonna
so with comedy they can hate on you but
the economy store whoever what whoever
Sam triply if you put one you're not
gonna be successful if you're not funny
it doesn't matter it doesn't work now
the crab that crowd especially at the
Comedy Store
yeah does not give a [ __ ] if it's the
right table cruises up there
he has its honker um I've made it I'm
like no Tom gets five nope I give a
minute
thirty at the star cruise in it thirty
Tom Cruise gets five min away people are
gonna be bugging that it's Tom who's de
taille jawbone know where chin line you
put them up first and they're like oh my
god some cruise but if he's following
like a legit comic Tom Cruise on a five
minute away dude not in la-33 minute
threes Jenna I'll give you three three
two three in the belly room so but but
but because you made my plug about you
Michael Rapaport combat Michael Rapaport
comedy calm Portland Sacramento Thank
You gun in Sacramento a Philly Baltimore
Boston the end of the 2019 disruptive
comedy tour that's done for 2009 teens
men I appreciate that
Michael rapport comedy calm no one's for
you do you bring guys with you it
depends I have I have mixed feelings
about how much you need - I like local
guy talk to me about it no cuz you know
I've got bit I've been headline now for
three years you like doing a three-year
headline for three years
yeah three years so for the first two
years I would just go it just be me my
brother my brother's my tour manager
whatever see we go into I wanted to see
how the other comics were because when
I'm at the store at the Laugh Factory
everyone's so good I'm like well I know
where I'm at with these guys yeah you
know these guys so I'm gonna go out
where people are kind of my level see
with that and it would be hit or miss
some be phenomenal others be [ __ ]
terrible scene but I learned the ropes
I've seen nothing but everybody who's
open for me on the road in Florida about
how in Florida good good what club palm
or was thing I did my I did to Miami and
I did West Palm Miami improv though were
you there with Institute - one bigger
dude and one older guy would mean bigger
loosely one one's a fat guy who's notice
and the other guy for you Ricky a
cameraman the name but they all I
haven't had a weird experience they've
all been cool they've all kicked ass and
they've all and then sometimes I bring a
guy and and you know I'll let you open
for me at some point if you want you
know
but I'm a jury now the the the other
piece of business I wanted to get to and
I wanted that I told Kalyn last night
when I saw him creeping around the
[ __ ] Laugh Factory 11 o'clock get up
Bobby get him a goose you're on set
doing a show like when I'm going set out
the next day I'm I'm sleeping or I'm at
home learning my lines well that's why
you're like a red boy doing my K that's
why that's why I enjoy on Netflix third
season and that's why I ain't never been
cut out of no movie
I ain't never been cut out of no movie
cuz they're like it's too good even if
it's even if it's it's just too good but
I wanted to bring this up with you
because I was gonna post yo coming on
the fighter and the kid today yes okay
and like I said I do consider you a
friend
I consider Cal and a friend we've always
been mutually supportive though and you
threatened me Earl you said you'd [ __ ]
me up and all that stuff I'm ready to
put this down like this because when I
was on my way over and I was like I was
gonna go yo on my way to fighting
hurricane and and I took a picture I did
a little one of my classic videos my
videos are kind of iconic now are they
come on I I mean when I put that camera
up like this it's like that's true it's
a it's like it's like the world start
thing it's saving the waters well it's
always like I just wait for you as soon
as like something pops off like LeBron
does this or you know this player does
this I tuned in it's you on worldstar
like you know is did you say that you
said you tune in on me a worldstar
because of what I wanted to bring up to
the to the viewers as a friend yeah is
that I noticed and I took down my video
because I said I'm gonna post video and
then my friend pointed out to me he said
you know that a fighter and the kid
they don't follow you and I said what do
you mean I go Bryan Callen did Brett and
job of course I will the fighter in the
kid the podcast says which you probably
run no okay do you what's your name
Kat Kat okay your cat yes okay bro
cat runs it should I see my friends
Brendon shop and Bryan Callen do not
follow me and I was like cuz I'll see
you on worldstar I was like wow that
hurt Joy's on PR skip receive a kiss yes
now who's me I was like nah not one of
them both of them so it had to be a
collective thing between the [ __ ]
think tank and we're talking about when
we say things a great quote cuz the
think tank between do because that
[ __ ] concrete [ __ ] hitter help me
fall Jeff 1.7 million like let's say 1.7
659 and it was 61 but I lost two and I
would like to know when the conversation
happened and I want to be straight here
let's be transfer when did you and cally
collectively go we're not following our
friend Rappaport I wonder I know there's
a [ __ ] conversation don't mean bribes
I've never had it comes it's very
strange and you guys are are you guys
like loose you'd be nice to who you do
follow just follow him right now ken has
accessed my Instagram that's
unbelievable
do you follow me [ __ ] I thought I
followed you cuz you're on worlds yeah
all the time hopping and the Nick do
anything I just gotta [ __ ] take my
man slowly to me the Wendy Williams of
London comedy and it could happen but my
man but my man the fact that it wasn't
just you can play count counts 6960 know
unless you have big titties I'm a dude
with a great heel for so there was a
collective thing all that strange
Brenda's and he followed you before like
Brendan's like this is a Brendon follow
some of the people like the generics the
Jeff Ross is everybody loves a world
with our mouths friend of mine but all
these people like all they're all the
check mark all like all these comedians
and like Fresno Travis Barker a really
good friend we know all this stuff and
now like I guaranteed you and I friend
I guarantee there's the top 15 people
that you follow hear me and you are we
could say I agree you you agree if
chicken ain't [ __ ] it's to fit I call
rap bag I know rap is not a bitch-ass
[ __ ] yeah you don't follow me
well I follow you now hunka you follow
him now but the fighter in the cuticle
has always followed you yeah because
because you follow it because you do
that's a business account but personally
said you see how my feeling could be
that invites fair sorry I apologize I
thought I was following you so I'm
right now I'm gonna I'm gonna [ __ ] your
blazer up I'm gonna [ __ ] your blazed up
for you go to Portland dude don't worry
my Blazers like don't don't worry at my
place that's a new don't tase me bro
this is Cal hey scumbag give me the
toilet hey scumbag hey scumbag come here
check this out scumbag I posted I just
asked your friend I asked him this nice
makeup by the way I said to him I
noticed cuz I was gonna do a post oh
yeah I'm doing fighter in the kid and I
posted something and somebody was like
you know those guys don't follow you on
Instagram so and both of you both of you
I want to know collectively be honest
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] mutant you
[ __ ] makeup face mutant be be honest
when did you when did you in [ __ ]
concrete head say Brian no we're not
gonna follow Rappaport anymore he's our
friend right looks like earthworm jim
right now face both wait and don't say
you're 60 and i'll cuz you know how to
work instagram last night you told me
you were 53 when you were creeping
around the Laugh Factory and you didn't
have a spot that's weird bro that's
weird what were you doing there no let's
stay focused I want to know a hospital
gown I want to know when did you decide
I'm not following my friend Rappaport
and why you're so precious but you
follow other people that if it was
ride-or-die you know you would call my
crap before because my crap is a solid
dude and all these [ __ ] leeches
backstab and leaves I jerked the icy
hose will I'll follow i G hos before I
follow either one of you
I found a gentleman but you you [ __ ]
your and we were already talking about I
want to see the joke or twice I haven't
seen you in it but
other thing we're talking about today
Callen is this is and you probably have
covered this who whose [ __ ] did you suck
first when you were with Pacino and
Schwarzenegger and I think all rap I had
to hear about it for a week dude he
wouldn't shut up about it he's senile
he's 83 years old he's dumb okay well
listen I just want to remind you Brian
that had last time I the last time I
guest-hosted it was the highest
downloaded fighter in the kid ever
yeah what's true we're were word yeah
we're taking over your Instagram okay
you're following me and you're plugging
every one of my shows you [ __ ] mutant
you makeup face mutant [ __ ] you let me
tell you something
that one tweet is about his mood the one
second that you were in the [ __ ]
Joker you feel dude so he went to that
party at Stallone's house how did that
even happen
show me I'll tell you so mean him at the
shoot is short for he's I'm sure your
fans are priority hurt he for time now
it's all they don't know this stuff so
meet him at to shoot this commercial the
next day and we're there I could tell he
like he kept calling me but I was an
answer let me see y'all [ __ ] date
would call me so I see mine said he's
like long night last night cool man he
goes I was at Stallone's house and yeah
so faster he was yelling oh that's cool
I keep on with my day he brings it back
up man I tell you one thing about
Stallone's house like all right man go
what is it what is it and it's Stallone
Pacino who else was there
Arnold Schwarzenegger Agron but
he'd get invited because his boy frank
grillo all right he was at him with him
he was the plus one plus one
Frank got invited bill burr was there
bill burr was and they got invited but
how did they like how does that did such
a disconnect with with Bill burn them
and it just did Stallone and and and and
and Al and I think they all hang out
talking about like the glory days on trt
what CRT testosterone replacement
therapy soon as that would count is
they're talking about the John Callen
into if you don't say like Oh make these
next 20 years of your life worth living
bright for bright show be a video of it
and it granted so that's something you
do where the [ __ ] you want to do he's a
legend
there's just pictures of semester stolen
all over the walls just like giant
paintings that's pretty gangster its
yeah he painted them have you have you
worked with him any of those guys uh
yeah well I did a film did phone call
Copland it was with Robert De Niro
Sylvester so did you ask drew drew Carey
who is it Dana Dana Carvey did you were
ya Copland do you ever see Copley and
Brendan do you know if you ever heard a
cop when familiar cobwebs you're in it
I don't know you're [ __ ] I don't know
your resume rap you know we're mouths
when I'm on again Portland Sun okay my
family
boom sacrament a punchline can't wait
good well you invite your boys the great
clubs some of the best clubs in
literally some of the best couple in a
choice from what uh Sacramento do your
big Diaz Bros fan are they up there
they're there in Stockton which is right
up there yeah I [ __ ] with the Diaz
brought was that I [ __ ] with them hard
you were at that fight dude you were the
thought in the back
nah dude I see I know I see like this
oh crap homie back homie I'm off yo
thanks ed you know what I realize I was
like why is rap acting like yeah they're
like you sure I have my hair dyed yo you
know what I realized about about being
that close to two to two fighters that I
love Derrick Lewis because I know him
well and kind of you know but like once
you for me for fighters you meet him you
know you you just have like you want to
see the win of course so you just have
and he's such a lovable guy right the
best so so when he like I blacked out
when that dude had his arm I blacked out
like I was literally like it was like
rocky to to me like I was like like like
people am I sitting next to me I was
sitting next to my man style bender is
he is he my boy yeah yeah um he did your
show I wouldn't say your guys ever have
a meal we had a meal okay Brita on the
show and outside the show okay all right
well the thing is is I I blacked the
[ __ ] out but between him and and Diaz
like I was like y'all it's like when you
did you know a mom just cuz it's
different I want them to win like I
wanted them to win and I [ __ ] with Jorge
it's harden it like that fight was like
you have to like both of them I don't
have you met Jorge never met horray but
Nate's my guy I never met me if you met
Jorge young man never made me never met
knees so new ones your guy you're a fan
I'm a fan I'm a fan well don't say my
god well Derek's my guy cuz I know um
have you had a meal with him yes
no no meal but I just a superfan real
fan your fan I'm not a super fan I'm not
super because I don't know all the [ __ ]
but the one dude the Magna dude that was
in Kobe Kobe um it was he interesting
before he put did people know him before
he put on that hat who's he fighting
next uh tomorrow spent for the title and
it was the thing about Colby
so it's on that before he's about to get
cut from the you see before he was like
[ __ ] now any favorite things out came up
with this huge gimmick and now you know
I'm right because the idol and he's like
the bad guy but the mag a bad guy it's W
dude he wants to go wob after this who's
gonna win life you meet Colby like I had
Kobe on the show on this show yes I know
or they're my food truck I don't bring
fighters on the ship food fight
franchise to [ __ ] them but no but food
truck is all fighters muchacha
fighters that's where I do just MMA
content but with Colby if you met him
he'd be your guy phenomenal guy great I
can't rock with you a few so for that
mmm I'm Tony it's such a it's such an
act for him like Ric Flair oh yeah hips
to him it's like WWE he's I can't what
why not you behind me okay okay I don't
know what what else would I do
you got you I got you um you would love
them okay but I [ __ ] with Nate III do
you know like with Nate and Nick [ __ ]
Diaz a trouser does the [ __ ] D I
also want to say at the old studio and
by the way why do you guys keep changing
Studios you running from bill no
collectors don't know every time I come
here a new [ __ ] studio knit money
bill collectors money women make money
tour owing it make and then notice how
it's an upgrade every single thing this
is an upgrade the last three ones it's
like oh we're running from the built
this one's an upgrade this is nice
wheeled the building got so here this
red we shoot three show you own the
building we run the building run the
building watch three shows you shoot we
do I do this here King the sting next
door and then below the belt falling
door and then the whole pod Bay's right
there okay what's up bro alright easy
now easy now I [ __ ] with you I know you
do or here's here's part three because
the fans also have asked this and and
I'm gonna I have a heart out now we have
the report three hours early for your
flight to Portland dude which is an
hour-and-a-half flight I know I just
what I don't listen I'm with you I don't
like the rest lady either here's the
other thing your yeah you know without
are you on that golden goose you [ __ ]
with golden funds was going me too I was
gonna write for you I [ __ ] with goose
yeah you you give hook up goose
sometimes but but they're there because
they're dope yeah people end up on the
gooses no expensive shoe for what they
are
yes but they're dope though they're
great um here's the thing again talent
to peers he never wears him he wears
these busted ass shoes anyway carry on I
need to get that knee that hook on yeah
okay here's the thing though you
mentioned theof one and three Studios
ago I created the guest of the year that
was my idea
I said I'm the guest of the year yeah
well it's my idea no
oh don't make me look up the tape I said
I am the guest of the year I guess they
ever how much you want to bet you
mother's all right but you might have
said I'm the guest no I read I started
the whole guest of the year thing no one
was talking about the guest of the year
on this show because at the time it was
clear-cut Rappaport is the very best
[ __ ] thing that ever happened to the
Aryan carry on so then like a year I
think maybe Theo came in with his belt
he smelled like [ __ ] fish spraying
body oil and lube and anything I've seen
people like oh he should be the guest
here and then I think they were maybe
saying D'Elia should be Greg guessing it
was good there was another person Lobby
Lee's very good these guys are cruel
none of them are as good guest of the
year this is the best fighter in the kid
podcast of a person that we know when
you get like a guest like Dana Carvey or
one of these guys that day then you
could that's an outsider but as a
recurring guest cuz you notice I didn't
come on I was like I'm gonna wait til
the end of the year I'm gonna let all
the [ __ ] smoke clear you could have
all people you want [ __ ] the red
rocket D'Elia
you can Bobby Lee come on and we all mmm
and then I say I'm gonna wait till
November I'm gonna do my thing and clean
up clean up clean up shut it the [ __ ]
down and you could have a feel for this
non-sequitur southern [ __ ] southern
charm [ __ ] I like it with the mullet
oh yeah I don't have a wife at the same
haircut since 99
1998 well-documented 89 it's well
document so so win it so instead of
saying oh who's the guest of the year
I'm gonna I want to say this it's the
fighter the fighter in the kid Michael
Rapaport award so you can give it a
listen we just call it the michael
rapport or alright but it's the fighter
in the kid michael rapper we'll just
Michael Rapaport guest of the Year award
there it is could be that there's really
nobody that you can get I don't give a
[ __ ] what hot sweet dick comedian that
comes on here talking anything the guest
of the year
who do you have on your on your show I
don't need no guess we do not have gone
solo on that I just ran solo on this
down so low on that on that ass it's
solo another 45 55 minutes a good of
pure fire
sugar [ __ ] good [ __ ] sugar [ __ ]
50 minutes of pure [ __ ] fired Icahn
firing on sports
no no it's [ __ ] wild because here I
am yeah you don't listen to the pockets
you don't watch I gotta listen to
podcast [ __ ] ape whoa bro Jesus
Christ little bit too much free content
to be behind a paywall you're not even
on YouTube so me we listen let's not get
into that okay see YouTube account any
of it that's not true listen I do what I
do
everybody does what they do I wish you'd
let me help maybe we'll discuss at some
point maybe we'll discuss at some point
we'll discuss some point you guys but
you don't just rant rant rant about
sports whenever I see her sports take
Emily's it's just watching it social
media reason should in your take though
cuz you what but why does certain times
you go on these PR like like you're all
over right like where were yesterday I
see you on all on disappeared good
morning I wake up my watch all my shows
hours I see you bouncing from one to one
like a [ __ ] I was gonna spot just now
Bam Bam no I don't make the outgoing
calls they call you to come in I mean it
is what it is it is what it is good
takes but also I think what helps you to
is cuz you know basketball the NBA's
never been hotter never been out I'd the
biggest since the 90s it Jordan days you
know yeah
are you following oh yeah what weary
where's your head add so far um it's a
it's a bummer the Warriors are just done
done
I think we're this year with Steph
Curry's I got my hands broke I'm out cuz
they were gonna suck it broke his
[ __ ] hand yeah you didn't see it come
back you come back he'll be back yeah
Heymann clean I've done for the year but
no hey I bet you him and clay Oh make in
the fall they'll play a few games I mean
in the spring they'll play they can't
compete though no but next year they'll
be the Warriors again they'll have dream
on they'll have both of them and I
guarantee I'll get a pickup don't don't
count the reward this year's a wash this
is definitely a loss but but next year
Steph and
and and they're both they're coming back
and they'll get a pickup like they'll
sign a free agent
yeah but then I went in Championships
again you don't know who they're gonna
stay here oh I'm not saying I think you
don't think if they get one big free
agent
why would if they get one big free agent
why would they want to camp with you
without Kevin Durant Kevin Durant made
it simple different animal now though
Kevin it's a different animal now in the
West different it's a different animal
now but if they get a free agent
first of all staff healthy staff healthy
clay and healthy dream on your dollars
fourth seed third seat five for sure
okay so so weird they're going to sign
somebody and they've never been like the
recruiting types after the Kevin Durant
cuz they didn't need how much more can
you get their draft that curry calls you
he's gonna start being like yo come out
here what is he called though that's
worked I'm saying next year they'd
Angela Russell's a good pickup also he's
good but they need they they don't
you're never gonna get lightning in the
bottle with Kevin Durant again that's
never had no I mean he was well they
could get his tenure in in gold state
was oh my god he you think he's mean a
salute Brooklyn slice slice you throw
what you think needs to be nasty with
Brooklyn I think thank God counts not
here to ruin I think that he will be
very good in Brooklyn but I think that
Kyrie and Kevin Durant are not gonna win
a championship
they're both defers I don't think you
can win one with Kyrie I wouldn't with
all this [ __ ] eautiful watch it's fun
when I'm a player and if I was if I was
at the Barclays watching him I'd be like
oh they are the best jerseys I think now
- they're the black I think the courts
say the Instagram highlights are sick
everything snow but you know what him
like like when you play boy you're like
you I'm waiting for you to pass yeah
after while you're like yeah [ __ ] it
you're not gonna Pat why my hand this is
this is too much energy like this is an
outlet here's what's crazy how [ __ ] up
are your Knicks that everyone was like
nah we're good it's literally every big
name was like oh no we're good and then
just hear Durant go on I he was 97 it
was like they're just not cool I that
was the last time I went viral
was it really cuz I to Rance my guy I
loved room but I had together that's my
favorite player I had to
not that though yeah and I'm sure you
did cuz you're [ __ ] die hurt Knicks
fan
he's kind of right though like the
Knicks aren't cool my main sport for
kids like like remember they medicate
anymore how do you you push up forty
thirty six you're on the other side
here's the thing though Knicks have
never been good as long as I've been
alive
Carmelo was all right there but they
weren't kind of [ __ ] they've never been
good
they've never so they're never cool like
you're not you see me rocking and good
but the Warriors weren't cool until they
became cool your your your your Denver
Nuggets now our back to be your Denver
like you might good ones a kid 95 Matteo
but but but your your your your that's
your that's my squad starving right Yes
sick but Jamal Murray I'll do first I
mean first team All Pro he's nasty yeah
and we got the homeboy from Missouri
nasty yeah who sat out of here yeah
really good we're taught to and you guys
could give a problem to the Lakers [ __ ]
yeah yeah court
yeah so we're top to top three jazz
they're they're getting cool now it's
like you go through waves I know nothing
makes no I know there's way I know well
just shitty and there's a Lambs and then
there's a river there's waves and this
is just like a shitty strong I wouldn't
call shitty strain over stagnant string
just like like a swamp but and there's
also no hope either like there's no like
well at least we're gonna get this guy I
know man I know it is very demoralizing
isn't it tough like new at sports are
it's not New York sports that the
heartbeat of NYIT's the Jets it the net
with the Giants listen the Giants as a
Giants fan we always want to see us do
good the fact that while Tom Brady and
those guys are still thriving they know
and we know what we did to them it's
like we [ __ ] it's like the great Tupac
said about Biggie Smalls
that's why i [ __ ] your [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah oh when we beat them
twice in the Superbowl lesson with
that's Tupac that's why i [ __ ] your
[ __ ] you know it's cool yeah
[ __ ] but here's that you found
out literally I know I hear you interval
here and you guys are hanging on to that
but patrons like cool hold my beer we're
gonna go win more I can't you guys are
[ __ ] Terry I get that but but but
it's
like the Knicks see the Knicks is next
we have se Quan Berkeley and the
quarterback I think could be some hope
there but did the Knicks is 1973 the
Knicks ER is terrible so that's all
about the Knicks the the the threes the
Jordan threes they released recently and
I was kinda like Knicks Jordan threes
yeah they really liked these Knicks
Jordan threes i bottom they're white
with the the nick colors how's it kindly
people think their meds are you a
sneakerhead
like a legitimate yeah have you been on
any one of them sneakers head shows i
have it i got asked to when I was in New
York when I was doing the promo for my
special but I couldn't fit it in so the
complex for saying yeah when it wouldn't
I'm probably the biggest thing head you
know I would say oh you're really hard
by jet sneakers so what's your most
valuable pair of sneakers to you
personally and then monetary like what's
the one you hold the highest regard for
and then what's the one that is the
worth the most dang that's a good
question I'm Michael Rapaport why are
you thinking about it Michael Rapaport
calm be calm
Portland this weekend figure it out so
Man X once the Jordan 3 retro Knicks and
then I'm gonna be in Philly first time
Boston that come you don't get them
Michael right I'm not a big sneaker dude
I'm not a big sneaker dude what size
shoe do you wear
12 what are you giving you those 13 like
that's your shoe man maybe you look dope
in those right yeah you do you ever give
a guest gifts if you're not going to get
my friend a pair of kicks
yes yeah those I wouldn't rock those are
[ __ ] you white I don't like white sneeze
them shits are ugly Duke shits right
Lakers shits all yes I don't but I like
my my most valuable shoes would be my
crab that's all the off whites the
vaults all blazers I got all those
literally all of them the the shoe that
I shot my special in is a Jordan Union
the shoe surgeon do shoe sure he's
yellow
he just gave me a pair of these
[Applause]
oh god what are their for what the eff
Air Force Ones they're dope dude it's
the best shoe I've ever seen a person I
was gonna do you did the David Spade
show yes so tore it up I'm sure you did
great more two torn up tuned it up I was
great well take it easy
I was great yeah you're all right I mean
I was great
you've already again yeah but I'm not
gonna day though yes is they book me all
right but I'm not gonna do that though
oh really I love that you know my mom
and tell you my 20s say my crap because
we're interviewing each other say my cuz
we're heading to the end of the year
hey rabbits 2020 what's your new year's
resolution just do it like let's do it
like it's not like we but kind of man so
to that 19's wrap it up yeah 2020 what's
your new year's resolution oh that's a
good question I've actually been
thinking about that a lot Brendon my
2020 resolution is I'm not doing any
more podcasts
no more guest [ __ ] no more podcast no
more nothing you just so 49 tween you're
gonna shut the [ __ ] up no I'm not but
here's the thing in a nutshell your
resolution to me I'm gonna shut the
[ __ ] door of podcast your tour should
be called rapport shut the [ __ ] up 20 20
20 that's not a bad tour 20 20
shut the F up I like that there you go
that's not bad yeah but I picture you at
tape of your man are you exhausted of
the revolving door of podcasts do you
get asked a lot and you don't do them
that much
I don't do I only do sure if it's a good
friend I'll do it but even though I'm
timid and even then it's tough vodkas
podcasts are literally like [ __ ]
[ __ ] everyone has one the everybody
yeah but only a few are good but but but
but everybody has them and now I have to
say I'm not doing them all but I think
most people that have them know I'm not
gonna do them all so I do two on Monday
sometimes two on Tuesday and then one on
Wednesday and then I'm on tour Thursday
Friday Saturday so it's like it's tough
man yeah that's a lot that's a lot of
talking I'm sick of myself I don't know
why people listen that's what I'm saying
you mean listen this there's all this
though just in general and but it don't
do listen to this but it's me this one
here I mean you're like what a [ __ ]
Pleasant [ __ ] surprise it's you and
it's kind of like Alan's good
did you see the impeachment yours do you
know I read this book about in 1947 and
there was a mother v didn't read [ __ ]
[ __ ] I saw you at the Laugh
Factory 11:15 the night last that you'd
have a spotless is a TED talk on his way
here and they regurgitates it towards me
J no I was thinking no you mean you
heard on those
regurgitating some other smart guy hurts
a dude on 20 october michael rapport
yeah welcome dude yeah sure it's i get
all sorts idea but it's out of control
though brendan with the podcast it's not
my plumbers got one my electricians got
one again but again only a few are good
but everyone asks you to be on them
no but you just say no right dad sir I'm
sorry saying no do you say no to a lot
of TV gigs I'm sure whenever there's
like breaking news people hit you up
yeah but I mean you know in regards to
sports I love talking about sports so
much like like the other day when they
were threatening to fire phys Dale the
Knicks coach I'm like you're not firing
Fidel without firing the [ __ ]
president of basketball operations that
[ __ ] stiff Steve Mills he's the worst
so you'll just let just fire everybody
you ain't firing physio unless you we
fire this [ __ ] guy first you've been
here through the whole tenure awful also
get rid of the team no but the thing is
like Dan Schneider with Redskins like
dude there's one [ __ ] problem what do
you think it is these guys that are
making the decisions one of the Orion
sources with the Redskins it's yes what
do you think's happening you it's you
love you a [ __ ] you're now
you're you're you're a [ __ ] like a
little black mole know that that's
scratching on my ass it's so friend it's
been there and I thought oh this is
nothing
did something we got to remove that
black mole in the black mole James Dolan
he's the clam mole on all New York Fitz
plans New York Knicks change ass bye-bye
he's a little gnome he's got the beard
and works just for men [ __ ] the word I
don't like it they fired Marv Albert
have you have you have you seen that uh
I'm just thinking of some of these
sports personalities have you seen that
Instagram post its Stephen a Smith from
like 30 years ago and it went you know
before we just had a dream he's in a
wife-beater he's drinking kool-aid and
was like living out of his car it shows
him like in this little studio when he
was doing is that cuz I didn't hard and
it's like yeah Steven Naismith thirty
years ago had a dream living out his car
was drinking kool-aid right white bread
to make bragging for free for the new
station and said now Sunday nine million
dollar a year for him he's a pro nobis
he's the best in the business he's the
best at what his style is like as the
ranting you know his emotion
his you know his heightened exaggerated
perplexed the way he way he puts
together words his hot takes this hot
Tate's smart Timon smart guy and also um
his exaggerated um you know like he's
performing people don't get with
performer it's like Stephen a skip
Shannon they're performing performers
and that's why when I for me when I go
on the sport shows and I talk [ __ ] I'm
like yeah I believe that but I'm
performing like I'm nothing run on there
and like me just did like my smart take
but it's not as fun who wants to hear
that yeah of all those people more of
Albert is a performer he's only
performed yeah so people but would they
get they miss they think they take it so
literally I'm like oh it's like I did
you know one get off and after this you
know skip bayless and Steve Naismith you
know skip bayless is the one it was his
idea for them to do the show yeah like
he's basically the creator of all of it
skip is dope that's why Stephen a Smith
his I hold up cuz someone's like
tarnished him egos nothing to hold up
the only reason I'm here so skip bayless
knew of me they tried to dis him yeah
and was I call up you gotta twist it
right he's the whole reason this whole
debate shows right all this this was all
skip bayless is ideal if he's the
originator yeah all this he and I didn't
know that
I love skip he's dope and I love skip
and Shannon how about one skip had his
burner accounts though I mean how many
burners do you have zero bet Brendon how
many burners you have burning accounts
like Kevin Durant hell yeah I got
burners really I got burners on top of
burners thinking about [ __ ] you think it
is May you're a tool that burn accounts
I got burners on top of burners I got
burner Instagram burner faces well Julie
yourself earner Twitter's I talk enough
[ __ ] but I don't worry
don't worry you don't have to ask me the
fact that you're asking about social
media is more disrespectful than the
fact that you don't even follow no but I
should've walked out of this Holly bro I
should have walked out of this brother
follow you now I should have came here
punched you in our face what's good
what's good took your account and then
made you follow then bouncing and smack
[ __ ] out he one more time good
don't do that before I leave try anyway
listen I got a goat this is 40 43
minutes of fire I know your disease your
flights all the time
seven two and it's one no you're saying
my side this out you shown your age you
like to get there early I know you're
saying yourself god I wish rap would
come around more often
of course uh that [ __ ] that that that
that albatross around my neck [ __ ]
Brit up bet Bryan Callen but it's short
and sweet I said I said to Kat it's
gonna be short and sweet night when I
say I said 45 minutes of fury Irie
and what did you say cat thumbs up
something like that you like thumbs up
yeah like okay sounds good but but do
you do you handle Callens account - no I
don't okay so I'm gonna do a couple
things I'm gonna tag Brennan I expect
some repose and I can hollows your date
okay
because because I was I have to say I
was like damn that kind of I was like
guys wait up I'll say that is weird
why would you take the he'll fall me
like oh well I was going to bring it
here cuz and even and you know because
you don't have to cancel about six weeks
ago I had to reschedule yeah I've been
hanging on to it for that long and I
store you it's and I was like I'm not
gonna I'm gonna say it on there we're
talking at the store and text him but I
was like imma say it on the air so imma
blow up his [ __ ] spot
are you kidding real easy just hey bro
you don't follow my girl [ __ ] my bat not
in my bed not my bed I wanted to see
your eyes flutter be like oh I got
confused on now I thought you should
know I thought you were WorldStarHipHop
I thought you just were world spat yeah
Brian told her he can't hold it against
him he doesn't unless you're a CrossFit
dude or gal he is not he loves CrossFit
dude I'll just watch him staring at
CrossFit dudes gay man all right I gotta
go bro you're the best the best man
mummy Abbi shop today's fine the kid is
brought to you by CBS Sports HQ I might
have went to it to talk a few basketball
shop here with Michael Rapaport fancy
himself a sports head I'm Tom out CBS
Sports HQ the brand new streaming sports
news network it's live 24/7
and ready for this it costs nothing
that's right not a dime it's sports
coverage that's always on and always
free always free always on CBS Sports
HQs coverage always focus on the game
tons of highlights breaking news as it
happens trades fantasy advice something
that you can go to maybe literally
insight to your bets this weekend maybe
you're betting on the games maybe for
your fancy Pete picks you want to beat
your friends go to CBS Sports
HQ right now and don't forget you can
get access to all this great coverage
ready for free I don't mean free for a
week for a month you have to have some
special cable package nope none of that
free right now just download the CBS
sports app on your phone Apple TV
wherever you watch your stuff and get
CBS Sports HQ no fake debates just
sports for real sports fans and a great
price of free five five finger free
discount right you don't even need to
have to log in know that no need to sign
up for anything nope just download the
app CBS Sports app and watch CBS Sports
HQ today you're welcome hey Brian do you
have student loans are you daddy pay for
hey don't say there's no bonus have
freaking loans I don't well they charge
rates it's crazy so if you do have
student loans which is most of America
you can refinance them with earnest to
save you money or lower your monthly
payment it's very important it takes two
minutes two minutes online two minutes a
little financial relief goes a long way
student loan refinancing with earnest
can help you pick a monthly payment that
fits your budget so you can breathe easy
yeah exciting rate is fast and easy to
start complete a few questions online it
only takes two minutes like Brian said
and you're ready to go if they call FISA
mised yeah yeah dude her arms and no
fees yeah dude plus there that loves
earnest customer service the Ray at nine
point four out of ten crazy cool start
saving today our listeners get a hundred
dollar cash bonus when you refinance a
student loan at earnest calm slash
fighter that's a hundred dollar cash
bonus when you refine at the student
loan at earnest calm slash fighter
you know guys it's Bryan Callen I'm
shooting school today and Brendan's
getting a little food right now and well
I know that you had to endure Brendon
and Michael rapport without my cooling
temperament and I want to apologize to
everybody even as I speak I've got
roughly 20 minutes to speak and then I
have to get back in my car I'll be late
to the set and they'll be very mad at me
I have to get into my hospital gown get
my foot up and continue with the scene
but you know I want to talk to you guys
a little bit about time management and
because the fact is we're all gonna die
yeah we don't have a lot of time now I
have a little more time than most to you
because genetically I'm gifted and God
probably likes me more than all of you
but for those of you who are mere
mortals what do you do and fear your
immune system for your performance for
your essential nutrients for your
support and vitality what are you doing
for your focus on your brain whoa whoa
I'm in the middle of the deal and now
come on I'm not gonna do that I'm sorry
I brought it to this I brought it to the
screeching halt I was just talking about
how time management a lot of people
don't have a lot of time most people are
gonna die I'm gonna live longer than
most you including you because you're a
big man and you're gonna break down
early yeah and I said what are you doing
about your focus your brain your mood
your sleep your digestive health your
like you all are supporting your
vitality it's all about on it yeah for
those guys that need supplements and
then I have natural their body doesn't
make natural supplements like mine dude
if it aint steroids it ain't [ __ ] what
oh [ __ ]
Brandon what are you trying to say to
steroids all right fine
you know what if you want to get an
agent or use on it if you can't just as
you steroids natural is on it way
healthier way healthier better for your
brain can you take steroids for your
brain Brennan but you can you can't I
hope so Oh like cocaine yeah yeah and
Molly and mushrooms but if you got a
hold down a job you might want to go
with alpha brain you know I'm saying
especially if the drug testing
especially if they're drug testing on
the streets it is hot in the streets so
I'm just saying on it slash fighter for
10% off we just all great what's that
I'm calm I'm calm slash fun now how was
was wrapped that son-of-a-bitch wrap
came in hot super hot he said I got
something for you yesterday so I mean I
got something what what he's mad we
don't follow him
I don't know we follow I thought I did
I'm always on somebody's somebody else's
profile
I don't follow anybody cuz I don't have
time to scroll through everything I mean
you're on there a lot but I hear you
you're on there all the time but I hear
you all the time madam yeah but I like
to watch videos like I get it you're on
all the time all the time
no but pretty distracted no don't say
that honest no that's not true so you
know everybody's [ __ ]
notice how everybody's dick to their
phone I was just when people you know
addictive this very true
I've been getting a lot of uh I always
know we do a podcast that strikes a
nerve that does well when I get a lot of
people strangers saying they wanna [ __ ]
your wife nope that that yes where where
they love that that you cross the line
and also I'm getting hey you bop anybody
in the [ __ ] the [ __ ] I'm like
rinks bottom in the [ __ ] it's good
stuff the funniest is people think we're
serious dude that's too much I'll get
people damaged you know we cross line
with Brian you said you know you'd be
funny man but that's just like oh you
[ __ ]
how long have even listen listen oh yeah
I love them though they gonna [ __ ] Brian
Collins why I got invested emotionally
people Bobby Lisa I want to say this
Bobby Lee's sister-in-law said that I
was her least favorite guest on Tiger
belly I just got a text about that from
Bobby but no if not from Bobby from from
a longtime listener of mine friend of
mine goes Bobby Lee's sister-in-law the
sister of his girlfriend okay Lyla I was
at least hi every guest when I'm really
born on there though we're not serious
No
oh thanks oh sometimes if you don't have
the right chemistry Kingdom no I thought
we Bobby and I always get along but you
know what
[ __ ] that hurt my feelings did it sure
did
but also who cares I know but still how
dare you Kyla's her name July let's go
Bobby who's a straight-up dimepiece and
her sisters super hot oh great so she's
hot as well she hates me yeah great
great dad join the party okay but the
thing is is uh you know who stopped by
my house today
who are you the text go hey you home
from Chris D'Elia yo yeah he goes I'm in
the neighborhood the old really
dolia stop by the crib today yeah very
unlike him well he was over there doing
no Whitney Cummings podcast oh we live
like his father his father called him up
and I guess Chris had been traveling
around LA cañada where his mom where
they live and his mama's home and his
father who's Italian from Jersey goes
hey you open the lock-in yada
today Chris goes yeah he goes just
driving around yes yeah I guess what you
do
I don't know I'd coffee and saw a friend
he goes you did huh in LA cañada cuz cuz
ya didn't say hi you know your mother
was home right oh wow
and he goes I guess you stopped off you
say out of your mother when you're in
luck and yada for sure holy [ __ ] yeah
I've got a neighborhood that well let's
go Italian on me scared of ya my mother
you know the Italians are weird that way
because my mother Hunnam sense Sicilian
my mother like is very educated and all
but one time I told on my sister my
mother punished my sister and she
punished me for being a rat
oh yeah you got it you got it mate Chris
came over and he met the little man he
met the little dude Gigi was all about
him oh he's so cute
TT what's he about six feet tall now 56
4 okay all trapped out getting recruited
by Chicago Bears I went to food truck
diaries our boy Israel is taller than
you he's a holy boy yeah I sent my video
today because I someone sent me a video
of his car McLaren f20 s racing a gt2 RS
like real racecar drivers and the gt2 RS
one and I sent my video went this could
be us but you play
that's good that's good yeah yeah I
solved that McLaren that same one he's
[ __ ] big dude I mean that's crazy
that's a big fella with hands every bit
as long or longer than yours we got
another big food truck coming up next
week I can't say the guests cuz we're in
the middle of it trying to figure out
what we're gonna do I'm gonna find out
off air oh you are we got any current
events in sight we do jumpy lows yeah
gonna do at least you came over dude
rapport was fun think we can't let you
go we don't know if we gonna go will
you're letting me go cuz you guys you
guys I was everything was all set it
shoot they don't care but everything's
all set you'll see don't now this is
what happens you want to know what
happens you go you're there it's gonna
be a two-hour scene it's no problem
I'm there that's not the way it goes the
balloon gotta be late the balloon tech
guy no one ordered the balloon tech are
what does that mean well you know in the
scene you got a balloon a doggy balloon
we need somebody to do that yeah it's
like when is it going good until 11:00
so we have to do a scene before that so
have you ever done a shoot or we on set
with like oh yeah we're gonna have it
for about three hours
never but you know six hours like they
schedule it for me that like they
specifically scheduled the scenes so
that they knew I'd be done by 12:30 but
there's so much [ __ ] that goes into one
little thang to make a movie and that's
why I'm still holding on because I get
to go home there's a chance we do it
after lunch
so that would chance I could have I
would have to be there you know 2:30 and
not and didn't that what can you what's
this now okay couple quick ones just an
update with the Drake cam vlog Don
situation so it turns out that people
were upset that Drake started to perform
more than like two to three songs
because there were a couple people who
performed two to three songs right
before him and they thought that Frank
Ocean was gonna come after and Frank
Ocean was never set to act yeah he was
never set or Coulson's ever met he was
like put on the whole people assume that
because Tyler the Creator is cool with
Frank Ocean and Frank Ocean released
music just assumed yeah they assume but
it's like if you go to see like let's
say your plan to see
Goggan and you go out and do an hour
before him like what the [ __ ] dude yeah
where's the was the guy yeah something
they didn't like Drake they just do an
entire show but you know what he did
which is brilliant he killed it with
humor he did it like a [ __ ] high-end
comic would do look at this this is
after got booty hoes plot twists just
signed a 10-year residency I can't flog
sorry kids see you every single year -
you are 30 Drake they're great I love it
gotta do it you gotta use Ari kid he's
got a humor you see every single year
but he took it like a champ you said it
was a humbling moment and that every now
and then you just got to be reminded
that's and then went back to his whiny
million-dollar crib it was like nobody
things are good success like that is not
an accident he's fine he'll weather it
he figures it's so funny know he's aware
what's going on girls don't like him
though right girls love him love him
okay what else you got okay so just
really oh I saw this goodwill chat there
was a high school boy who came out of
the closet when he was in middle school
he got bullied a lot growing up and just
the other day he posted up a video of
him and somebody who was bullying him he
said that another kid in his school took
a snapchat photo of him and said
something derogatory about not liking
gay people and it made its way around
school he saw it he then approached the
kid asking hey why did you post this
about me and he the bully proceeded to
then call him a [ __ ] and he said don't
call me that
if you call me that one more time like
he's out I fired yeah he's just got like
a be like Oh see get you like that oh
that's a gay little boy yeah play the
video and it's a fantastic
[Music]
he's not small either
yeah I'm not playing with you he said
get out my face
that's him smack him there's a better
video of him smacking him he slap the
bejesus out and it's coming right now
oh my god why am the initials math
teacher yeah also teacher what are you
doing but did terrible teacher
the initial slap is so hard that wasn't
that big yeah you can he talks back it's
like yeah you can't Samana joy you can
knock somebody out he's Logan Paul about
something else laughing so he ended up
getting suspended for a couple of days
he found somebody who recorded that an
encounter and he posted it up onto
Twitter which went viral right yeah a
lot of people reached out to him saying
that like okay I don't violence what the
[ __ ] were you say to the face get ready
for this all these get here about Morse
that kid just got but look that kid
keeps come back word though and here's
the thing the the gay kid not small it
was like you're gonna bully him look at
him he looks pretty athletic too like he
puts it on there's his turn turns his
hips I would be so disappointed that was
my son who's making fun of gay people
and they got slap like that and got beat
up well I hope you learned your lesson
dumb idea yes there's a thing there's a
thing yeah here's the thing you just
need somebody to teach him why that's
not a good thing that's a young boy who
needs to be educated you gotta get
checked
now he's now now it's gone viral he's
the kid luckily we can't see his face
but the whole school knows who it is
yeah you're the kid who got beat up by
the gig I got beat up by a gay kid not
cuz I called him an but I thought I was
tough and I hit him and he hit me back
and I he was much bigger pinned you down
I mean oh he hit me back and I went
and he hit me like a child does hit me
the back of the neck I went I went Jesus
I sobered up right quick and I was like
cuz I threw a punch first and he just
went but boom camera up if he hit me in
the face I remember an American how old
were you oh you know that a spider and I
I was like I don't want any part I just
stopped and he was so nice that he
stopped and I kind of like change the
subject
and then something goes in you guys and
we act like nothing happened just
embarrassed but it is so quick so
quickly ascertain the fact that he was
much bigger and stronger and I was like
this and I was quiet and that's some of
the we started talking acting like
nothing I was really hurt I was like
yeah so what are you gonna do cool some
kid goes are you guys friends still and
they came to he was so sweet he looks me
and went I go yeah I think us yeah thank
God and for the rest I know I pocket for
the rest assured and walked around where
my index finger looped and it was belt
look I'm at my buddy starting [ __ ] cuz
we were when we wrestle in middle school
or he'll shot the Mustangs
we're there's a team came in I think it
was central or something like that
there's a girl on the team black girl my
friend Alan Kashani
Muslim kid goes dude you imagine
wrestling that [ __ ] girl
be so easy I'm like yeah I can you
imagine sure enough he gets paired up
she beat the [ __ ] out of him she pinned
him she pinned him and he never wrestled
another day and it ruined that broke his
back
we were all watching like oh my god she
like not like technique just body
slamming onto his neck pins him oh no
and then he was behind the bleachers
crying and now he's homeless
so that's a tough black girl was not
playing no no you can get I got beat so
badly but I'm tennis I thought I could
play tennis tennis and she was just at
all I was a young boy hadn't hit puberty
I was a girl short hair and she was a
gal she was a strong athlete like a
competitive tennis player she beat the
[ __ ] [ __ ] she was hitting the ball
I was hurting I was like I was I've
never been so embarrassed she just
crushed me cuz I was talking a big game
I was saying I'll take it easy on you I
told you time after I could do not to
drop a [ __ ] I'm gonna drop a [ __ ] yes
when I was a young fighter in Aurora at
high altitude I'm this big old girl this
big old girl kept getting super feisty
and I got paired up with I'm like well
no let's not do this she was gone real
real hard and then when no was looking I
gave her a [ __ ] nice old liver shot
you when I went down with oh wow you
know please give up please get up did
you try knocking me out
I know how to hit a [ __ ] deliver been
done before you guys send me hate mail
way bigger than me a hundred pounds on
me and was trained for many years nobody
has bigger nobody's bigger no woman is
bigger she's bigger than me
I'm not taller you're 200 why men thick
big girl big girl because I had to drop
a bit yeah well you know didn't come at
me again bro don't come at me yeah what
else we hit women so anyway um yeah and
you had a gay boyfriend ah this is so
funny so gross have you seen this have
you seen this yeah is this a real gist
she's really hot bit of a flat ass
whatever you don't think so but that was
white blue smoke similar to what people
do for gender reveals they're off see
just patrolling right they're trolling
yeah view have you seen that girl she's
pretty hot she's on worldstar she's
Asian she farts everywhere she's like
really hot but she fights so disgusting
yes she's all like oh oh you like it I
can't discuss it everywhere like should
be like the brass and it should be like
ooh this restaurants good you're like
damn like the biggest days on the asian
girl sweet she's all it's so [ __ ]
weird it's uh hot girl farting so weird
I put a hot girl hot car on arts world
star
she's a asian chick no that's just of
okay go back the Asian girl as it is
that her there is that her whole
profiles check that's her is that yeah
yeah she brought right it's all she owes
fart look that's friggin gross don't see
the yellow she's hot though alright um
don't go the ones where she's farting
kid like this all she does go to one
what she's trying to look sexy though I
did it Jim the thing is she's stupid hot
this one Oh
did another surge brushing her teeth
she's just deep though oh good one when
she's in her car that's freaking
terrible she does know just that's a
joke like the Jack Nicholson joke yeah
she looks like she goes down I'll go
along she's in the green outfit yep and
then after go wish she's naked on the
Left go the one on the left like she's a
baddie that body's bangin we can't be on
there not farting like that can't be
your thing can you imagine that's your
girl like yeah yeah
hey like dude that's oh your Costa thank
you that's your thing you're the hard
group of instagrams [ __ ] that's fine
give us one more let me see her in the
water why is that one blocked out it's
probably good
oh well Jacuzzi anybody Wow all right
chin so just got good to blurt out one
what's going on with that
I mean her legs are up okay oh she
doesn't look that good face how funky
yeah that's her thing that's imagine if
I was my thing if you're like Brendan
are you trying to sell tickets and you
tall and you're farting I'm like yeah
man funny thing hey guys I'll be at the
fireman keep like he's the worst game of
all time
yeah Sasso says man just sends us you
know video of just him farting go to the
one let me get bohemian one more see
she's pretty hot dude you do what you
want when you're popping it's tough
though it says a million to almost two
million views she's so disgusted Oh guys
I got a run on ma let's end it on fart
girl yeah we girl well I appreciate them
in for 12 minutes you got a buddy it's
always great to be here love to do
something to pay so I have to it's gonna
have to start having at least I have to
start right now Wilbur theater Wow [ __ ]
you every one more loans what's the read
let's do it let me do my intro yeah I'm
in Dallas this Thursday Friday Saturday
all shows or damage sold-out set for
early show Friday on that the [ __ ]
sold out Salt Lake City Utah wise guys
next week and then Pasadena me and Bryan
Callen you ain't committed to it Ryan's
coming that is the 27th right before
Thanksgiving me Brian some other friends
yeah friends Brian okay dude you slice
out st. cyr than me and Brian once
you're only Kansas City December 6 to
the 7th and then Atlanta City New Jersey
December 14th La Hoya tickets just went
on sale December 19th to 21st get your
takes now to evac a comp well let's just
close out the show cuz in me right
[ __ ] that was the pre-roll all right do
everybody I'll see if I need to come for
eight minutes and farting into the mic
and thank you
this is the finally kid we're out
perfect